ДИНАМИЧНАЯ МУЗЫКА Musik Oh, her willkommen. Ihr wolltet einschlafen? Ihr habt diesen Podcast gewählt, um einzuschlafen? Nehmt das! Herzlich willkommen zum Aufwachen-Podcast, zur Stefan-Tietze-Florentin-Willshow. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Ich glaube, es gibt Leute, die schlafen schon während des Intros ein bei unserem Podcast. Wenn es so lang ist, ja, aber wenn es zu laut ist, nein. Aber auch schön, dass es so, obwohl es hier gerade leise lief in den heiligen Hallen des Podcast-Urwos, auch in den Studios, war es trotzdem übersteuert schon, was ich ganz toll finde. Ja, ich finde, Rock'n'Roll muss immer übersteuern. Wer bei Rock'n'Roll sagt, mach mal ein bisschen leiser, mach mal hier den Gain ein bisschen runter, Nee, Rock'n'Roll muss wehtun in den Ohren und ich finde, da hat Tobias Tobias, richtiger Rock'n'Roll-Name. Metal Tobias. Metal Tobias hat richtig gute Arbeit geleistet. Das ist nicht Rock'n'Roll. Die muss ich auch mal die Rock-Musikrichtungen durchgeben. Ist das Metal? Heavy Metal. Heavy Metal, ja. Aber interessant, ich habe nämlich noch nicht gelesen, dass der Fluch der Karibik Soundtrack tatsächlich ... Hat eine Minute für den Krieg gedauert. ... immer übersteuert. Der ist so schlecht abgemischt, dass der übersteuert. Und dann habe ich auch mal die ganze Story nachgelesen, wie es überhaupt zu diesem Soundtrack kam. Und die hatten einfach nur, ich glaube, zehn Tage Zeit oder so für den ganzen Soundtrack und für die Aufnahme des eben solchen. Und dann kam es eben dazu, dass der nicht so richtig abgemischt wurde und deswegen immer übersteuert. Man kennt es ja auch, dass bei Schulveranstaltungen, bei irgendwelchen Abi-Theaterstücken oder sowas, mal eben Flutterkaribik hergenommen wird für irgendwelche bunten, talentierte Abende und so.
Und immer übersteuert, über diese Boxen berattert.
Und man denkt immer, nee, wer ist hier gerade schuld?
Tatsächlich einfach, was ich nicht wusste, fucking Hans Zimmer.
Klaus Badelt ist schuld.
Das heißt, eigentlich müsste man da ein Statement mal verlangen von Klaus Badelt,
der sich an allen Grundschullehrern entschuldigt, wo die Kinder zu ihrer Zaubershow irgendwie, he's a pirate, unbedingt haben wollen. Du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du nach dem anderen zack, zack, zack. Obwohl ich finde, andersrum ist es noch schlimmer, wenn zu gute Musik genommen wird. Und zwar war ich mal bei einer Zaubershow und... Du bist da hingegangen? Nee, was heißt, ich bin hingegangen. Du hast dich schick gemacht. Also was heißt, ich bin hingegangen. Ein guter Freund von mir, ein Schulfreund von mir hat gesagt, ja, der spielt Klavier und der war immer der Krasse von uns. Der konnte am besten Klavier spielen, am besten singen, der war halt so das Musikgenie. Und der hat dann halt schon super früh Chopra gespielt und super krasse Sachen und so. Und er meinte dann, ja, er hat ein Konzert irgendwie, aber und wir alle, ja klar, kommen wir. Und er war schon von Anfang an so, nee, kommt nicht. Und man kennt das ja, dieses Hin und Her, dieses, ja, ich habe einen Preis gewonnen. Ach, wir kommen zum Preis, wie lange? Nee, braucht der nicht kommen. Und jeder weiß, es wird eh passieren, lass uns das Alpha skippen gerade. Und da dachten wir auch alle, es ging um Bescheidenheit bei diesem Herrn, der will nicht, dass wir auf sein Konzert kommen. Stellt sich heraus, das war nicht der Anlass. Der Anlass, warum er nicht kommen wollte, war nicht, dass er so bescheiden war, sondern dass er zwar Klavier gespielt hat, die fantastische Fantasie von Chopin, aber das mehr als Hintergrundmusik für die Zaubershow eines talentlosen 14-Jährigen gegolten hat. Das heisst, dieser talentlose vierzehnjährige ist auf die Bühne gegangen und hat zu wunderschönster klassischer Chopin-Musik irgendwie versucht, den Hasen aus dem Hut zu ziehen. Und es war schrecklich, weil wirklich mein guter Freund ganz links an der Bühne am Flügel saß, wunderschön gespielt hat, aber alle halt nur auf diesen schlechten Hasen gestarrt hat. Und es war wirklich noch schlimmer, es war wirklich Perlen vor die Säue, wo du dir wirklich dachtest, das verdient, also Chopin würde sich, ich glaube, der lebt sogar noch, der würde sich irgendwo in Elbe oder wo er stationiert ist umdrehen. Also es können sich auch lebende Leute umdrehen. Können sich umdrehen, das stimmt. Sie müssen nicht im Grab. Wieder Grundschulfeier dreht sich Klaus Mahler einmal auf. Aber Funfacts, die Leute im Grab nicht, die können sich nicht umdrehen. Das stimmt, das ist richtig. Aber ja, also da habe ich gelernt, nein, es ist noch schlimmer, wenn die Musik zu gut ist für den Anlass. Das ist völlig richtig. Und da muss man auch immer aufpassen, was man als Begleitekt nimmt. Weil du musst wissen, wo bist du? Auf einer Skala von eins bis wahnsinnig unterhaltsam. Und da muss man auch mal gnadenlos ehrlich sein. Da muss man garnadenlos ehrlich sein und dann überlegen, ja, vielleicht ist der Leierkistenmann dann doch der richtige Begleitakt für mich. Du musst in den harschen Entertainment-Spiegel schauen und sagen, Beethovens Fünfte, vielleicht ein paar Kategorien drüber für meine Tellerdrehnummer. Brauche ich das Prager Filmorchester? Nein. Nein, und auch eine Frage, die wir uns schon oft gestellt haben bei Live-Shows. Nehmen wir ein Orchester mit, dann doch, um halt unser Intro zu spielen? Antworten, nein, die Shows sind nicht so gut wie das Babelsberger Filmorchester. Wobei man da ja auch noch entgegenarbeiten kann, wenn man jetzt sagt, man nimmt irgendwie so ein Kinderorchester, lässt die aber irgendwie Mendelssohn spielen. Also Unfähige Interpreten können, dann brauche ich noch das Pendel auf die andere Richtung bringen. Im Schulorchester ist es für mich das Phänomen immer so toll, dass man schon während des Stimmens am Anfang erkennt, dass es nicht funktionieren wird. Der Teil, wo am Ende immer alle Instrumente den gleichen Ton spielen, ist der Moment, wo da nicht alle Instrumente den gleichen Ton spielen, und reiht man sich schon die Hände in erwartungsvoller
Freude, weil dann gleich der
ungarische Tanz dann doch nicht so
toll ist. Spätestens wenn der Dirigent
aka der Musiklehrer dann auf die Bühne kommt und
sagt, ja, der Robert,
die Melanie, Carsten und die
Elfriede sind heute leider krank,
aber dafür
spielt jetzt der Johann Trompete, der spielt
zwar normalerweise Geige,
spielt heute die Trompete,
aber das macht er auch gut und Robert
Das war's. Aber dafür spielt jetzt der Johann Trompete. Der spielt zwar normalerweise Geige. Die Saune? Er spielt heute die Trompete. Aber das macht er auch gut. Und Robert in der letzten Reihe zuckt die Schulter. Schüttelt ganz so mit dem Kopf. Nein, nein. Schüttelt den Kopf ist nicht dasselbe Instrument. Ach, das kriegst du schon hin. Der wusste es bis gerade auch nicht. Ja. Schüttelt ganz hochroh mit dem Kopf. Nein, ich kann das nicht. Ich erinnere mich auch noch, was mein Musiklehrer damals gesagt hat, ich habe Gitarre gespielt und habe dann in so einer Gruppe von drei Leuten und dann wurden auch ab und zu Konzerte gegeben. Oh, ein illustres Trio. Furchtbar. Und dann wurden auch manchmal Konzerte gegeben, irgendwie bei so Stadtveranstaltungen, auch teilweise draußen und die klassische Gitarre ist ja das schlechteste Instrument. Und war wahnsinnig leise. Wahnsinnig leise. Und dann hat mein Lehrer zu uns, weil der hat schon gemerkt, die Show läuft nicht gut. Ja. Ich meine, selbst bei so Shows, wo nur die Eltern kommen und einfach nur darauf warten, bis sie ein Foto von ihrem Kind machen können, selbst da haben ja die Musiklehrer immer noch den Anspruch, eine richtig geile Show abzureissen. Und die kommen dann hinter die Bühne und merken, fuck, fuck, fuck, irgendwie die Drittklässler haben nicht so performt, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe. Und dann kam er so zu uns mit so einem Ihr müsst jetzt die Show retten Blick und meinte so, egal wie ihr spielt, spielt einfach laut. Ihr müsst nicht gut spielen, spielt einfach laut, so laut ihr könnt. Und wir mit unseren mächtigen siebenjährigen Pummelfingern einfach schön in die Seiten. Aber furchtbar.
Natürlich furchtbar.
Aber er muss sich wegen dem Sturm ansprechen.
Aber auch gut, wenn dann neben euch ein Zauberkünstler anfängt, der euch die Show stiehlt, weil er wahnsinnig gut ist.
Und dann hätten die Zauberkünstler nämlich endlich mal das Blatt umgedreht.
Finde ich auch ganz gut.
Aber auch geil, wenn ein Pianistenkumpel irgendwann mal vielleicht der Begleitekt von einem fantastischen Zauberer wäre. Auch kann auch sein, ja.
Aber obwohl, wie heißt nochmal der Begleitpianist von David Copperfield? Weiß man nicht. Igor Levit. Niemand weiß es. Niemand weiß es. Er hat sich nicht gemeldet übrigens auf unsere Anfrage. Das heißt, wir haben einen weiteren Feind auf unserer langen Liste der Podcast-Ufo-Feinde. Naja, lange Liste, Christoph Fiedemann und Igor Levit, also vor allem eine sehr monothematische Liste. Das ist eine engelige Liste, ja. Die anderen reagieren alle. Ja, komisch, aber ich würde auch nicht mehr arbeiten. Leute, die Klassik. Wo wir schon beim Thema Feedback sind, um es mal in Anführungszeichen zu setzen. Es ist ja manchmal gar nicht so leicht, unsere Hörerschaft einzuschätzen, was da so kleben bleibt. Da haben wir zum Beispiel gesagt, spendet, um irgendwie Westafrika von der Heuschreckenplage zu befreien. Nichts. Da haben wir gesagt, schickt uns doch mal eure Kindergeschichten ein. Nichts. Da haben wir gesagt, hey, helft doch mal dem Schwimmbad da einen Namen zu finden. Nichts. Aber wenn man mal sagt in einem Podcast, dass der Plot von Die Schöne und das Biest keinen Sinn ergibt, dann sind die Schleusen offen. Dann wird geschrien, dann wird gewütet, da wird wild in die Tasten gehauen mit vielen Nachrichten, wo man sagt, hat das jetzt die Mühe gerechtfertigt, die dafür aufgebracht wurde, diese Nachrichtsformulieren? Ich bin bereit, diesen Kampf einzugehen. Wobei bei mir kam oft an einfach nur, du hast recht, ihr habt recht. Das kam auch manchmal an, aber meine These aus letzter Woche war, dass die Schönheit des Bies ergibt keinen Sinn, weil die Botschaft ist, man liebt Leute wegen ihrem Inneren und nicht wegen ihrer äusseren Schönheit. Aber der Plot heißt, hey, wenn du wegen deiner inneren Werte geliebt wirst, dann wirst du schön. Also die Botschaft beisst sich selber so ein bisschen. Und dann kam natürlich das klassische Argument, der Fluch muss nicht nur gebrochen werden, damit das Biest wieder schön wird, sondern an dem Fluch hängen ja, da hat der Herr Disney es wieder sich leicht gemacht, alte Drehbuchautorenschule, an dem Fluch hängen auch noch die ganzen Diener in dem Schloss dran, der ganze Kronleuchte, die Tasten.
Der wollte ja gar nicht unbedingt wieder schön werden.
Genau. Aber jetzt kommt mein Gegenargument. Das ist ein bisschen so wie Briefschach.
Ja.
So immer, es dauert eine Woche, bis die Antwort kommt.
Ich bin so ungeduldig für diesen Krieg, für diesen Kackkrieg.
Und mein Gegenargument ist, wer sagt denn, dass die überhaupt zurückgezaubert werden wollen? Beweisstück A, die singen und tanzen während dem Lied. Hast du schon mal traurige Leute singen und tanzen sehen? Nein, die freuen sich, jeder hat seinen Platz im Schloss, die singen und haben die Choreografie. Wenn ich für den Tag ein Kronleuchter wäre, würde ich ganz ehrlich auch singen und tanzen. Ich würde frohlockend Kronleuchter. Ich würde frohlockend singen und tanzen.
Ich finde, das ist eine sehr...
Ich habe gar keine, gar nicht zu sagen in der Diskussion.
Ich habe den Film nicht gesehen, ich habe die meisten der Nachrichten nicht bekommen,
weil ich nicht unsere scheiß E-Mail-Adresse eröffnen kann.
Ja, aber du kannst es ja nachvollziehen.
Ich kann es nachvollziehen.
Ich als Kronleuchter hätte die beste Zeit meines Lebens.
Ich würde singen und tanzen für einen Tag.
Danach würde ich vermissen.
Meine Hände, meinen menschlichen Körper, meine Größe, Tennis. Schokopudding. Verschiedene Sachen, was man vermissen würde. Vermissen und würde dann vor allem meinen Wachszustand nervig finden. Ich würde die Sonne vermissen. Ich finde es eine extrem herablassende Einstellung, einfach davon auszugehen, dass Gegenstände nicht Gegenstände sein wollen, mit ihrer Situation nicht zufrieden sind, sagt niemand. Was ist der zufriedenste Gegenstand? Gegenstände? Tacker. Gegenstände werden ... Tacker ist der beste Gegenstand, der einfach einen geilen Job hat, der einfach weiß ... Gegenstände das Musical? Ja. Gegenstände das Musical. Büro das Musical des Musicals, Objects, It's getting more generic, it's getting more vague and more generic every time, Objects, It's getting more static, they can't fucking move, they just sit there. Nach Hexen, Mormonen, Zügen kommt jetzt das Musical zu euch. Fuck it, jetzt ist eh schon alles egal. Objects. Pflanzen haben wir. Nope. Okay. Ja, vielleicht. Wir sind uns noch nicht einig. Nach letzter Woche Foods kommt jetzt noch langweiliger Objects. Objects. Tacker, aber finde ich gut. Aber die sind die Bösewichte. Das, wo man die Tacker-Nadeln wieder rauszieht, dieses Vampir-Ding, das ist auf jeden Fall der Bösewicht. Und was könnte der Protagonist sein? Das ist jetzt mal eine klassische Brainstorm-Aufgabe, die bei Pixar bestimmt schon stattgefunden hat. Was ist der Protagonist von Objects der Film? Weil bei Toy Story hat man sich für Cowboy entschieden. Nicht offensichtlich. Hätte er auch ein Ritter sein können. Hätte er auch ein Erdbeerbauer sein können. Oder so. Hätte ganz verschiedene Sachen sein können. Oder hätte zum Beispiel auch irgendwie so ein Kartoffelkopf sein können. War es nicht Cowboy? Welches Objekt ist der Protagonist von Objects 3D? Lass uns das direkt. Okay, aber das macht jetzt alles anders. Aber wenn es Objects 3D ist, dann ist natürlich, aber natürlich der 2D-Röhrenfernseher unser Protagonist. Der Fernseher ist der Protagonist. Ja. Okay, Probleme. Er braucht Strom. Das heißt, er kann sich schon mal erstmal nicht eineinhalb Meter weit weg von seiner Startposition begeben. Die meisten Object. Tacker nicht. Die richtig guten Tacker, ich meine. Ein Batterie betriebener Fernseher, sehr spezielles. Aber hat er dann sein Gesicht auf dem Bildschirm, einfach so, als der redet wie, oder hat er so ein ganz kleines Gesicht nur? Andere Idee, das Gesicht ist ganz unten, so neben dem ISBN-Code.
Weil das denke ich mir immer, die Gesichter bei Autos, Cars, haben sich das denkbar einfach gemacht. Die haben schon Gesichter. Wobei stimmt, sind die Augen nicht die Scheinwerfer? Ja genau, die Winterscheiben sind die Augen. Das waren die ersten Drafts, dass die Scheinwerfer die Augen sind bei Cars. Aber dann hat man gemerkt, nicht nur sehen die komplett bescheuert aus, sondern der Grossteil des Körpers ist dann nicht benutzt, sozusagen. Hingegen wenn die Winchertscheiben die Augen sind, dann hast du mehr ein Kopfgefühl von dem ganzen Auto. Aber das finde ich auch gut, bei dem Fernsehen die ausdrucksloseste Figur, die Pixar je hervorgebracht hat, die Mattscheibe ist komplett schwarz die ganze ganze Zeit. Ganz kleines Gesicht rechts unten. Hey Leute, hey, hey, hallo, Fernseher! Was ist die Stimme, auf die wir uns geeinigt haben? Hallo, ein kaputter Fernseher, wo nichts drauf läuft, die ganze Zeit schwarz. Ne, andere Idee, ich denke mal in eine andere Richtung kurz, ist ja Brainstorming, muss ja alles erlaubt sein, Powerbank, ein Objekt, das nur für andere Objekte lebt. Finde ich gut. Ja. Finde ich gut. Und der ist immer abhängig von anderen und sagt, ich habe kein eigenes Leben, ich bin ja nichts wert. Ist die meiste Zeit leer? Ich bin hauptsächlich leer. Schlapp, energielos, antriebslos. Der Domino-Effekt, je häufiger man auflädt, desto weniger kann er halten. Altert, ganz schnell.
Ja, kann man dramatisieren. Und natürlich,
ich glaube, kein Objekt wird so schnell ersetzt wie die Powerbank. Er ist so eine riesige,
klobige Powerbank. Und dann der
Andy-Versatz, wir nennen ihn jetzt mal,
wir nennen sie Brandy. Brandy.
Brandy, die junge Frau, die
die Powerbank hat, kauft sich dann eine
Woche, nachdem sie
die Powerbank gekauft hat, eine wesentlich kleinere und leistungsstärkere Powerbank und mustert die alte aus. Die sind in der Schublade. Und in der Schublade findet die Powerbank andere ausgemusterte Gegenstände. Wie zum Beispiel Tamagotchi. Ach, Stefan. Game Boy Color. Ja. Game Boy Advance SP. Ja. Furby. Furby. Oh Gott, Furby. Jojo. Auch der Furby, Funfact, hat die Augen nicht da, wo die Augen sind. Der Furby hat die Augen hinten. Ja, finde ich gut. Das Tamagotty auch. Keine Augen, gar nicht, kriecht rum, merkwürdig, schneckenmässig, so ein Weich, also alles, weil ich denke, das machen sich immer alle zu einfach mit den Äugleinen.
Ja, wir gucken mal. Also ich bin dafür Object der Film.
Jojo finde ich auch gut, Jojo, wo vielleicht immer die Schnur, hey, was geht, ja, unglaublich nervige Figuren, jede einzelne. Aber der, der formt seinen Mund mit der Schnur. So wie bei Soul, Freust du dich auf Soul, der neue Pixar-Film, der jetzt im Dezember kommt, mit dem Jazzmusiker und den Seelen. Da gibt es nämlich auch diese Leute, die in der Seelenwelt leben, die bestehen nur aus einer Linie.
Die haben nur die Kontur und dann diese gesamte Figur. Aber die haben es mittlerweile mit Musikern und Seelenländern. Coco war genau das gleiche. Musiker, Seelenland. Ich will was Neues. Also sorry, Kinder sind ein, es ist ein Unterschied, ob es ein Berufsmusiker oder ein Amateurmusiker ist. Das Kind aus Coco war kein Musiker. Die können sich alles aussuchen. Die können literally Objects 3D machen. Und was machen sie? Coco 2. Hör auf jetzt. Du machst mich ganz kirre. Es ist nicht Coco 2. Und wenn ich dich kirre mache, dann warte ich, freue mich jetzt schon auf meinen Mailpost. Es ist ein Berufsmusiker. Ein Kind, das eine Gitarre in die Hand nimmt, ist noch nicht dasselbe wie ein Berufsmusiker. So, jetzt schau den Film an und find dein dummes Maul. Ich werde vulgär, glaube ich, heute. Ich werde mal wirklich so den einen oder anderen Podex auspacken. Das würde uns nicht stehen, glaube ich, Vulgarität. Bist du ein Vulgarier? Nee, gar nicht. Florentinus vulgaris. Ich bin, ich finde das auch immer nicht so ganz lustig, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Vulgärhumor hat mich nie richtig gekriegt. Vielleicht ist es eine Verklemmtheit, vielleicht ist es irgendein Traumata, aber irgendwo kann ich da nicht so ganz abschwunseln. Ich bin da auch ein Verklemmt. Das Einzige, was ich manchmal, gerade weil ich nicht vulgär bin, können wir uns, und du ja auch nicht, können wir uns das so eigen machen für manche Witze. Zum Beispiel, wenn man mit einem netten Menschen redet, der ist vielleicht sehr höflich und dann geht er raus, verabschiedet sich dreimal, bis er sich endlich traut, das Gespräch zu verlassen und dann dreht man sich um zum anderen Gesprächspartner und sagt, Arschloch. So, klassischer Gag. Und der funktioniert bei anderen Menschen nicht so gut wie bei uns. Bei uns erwartet man das nicht. Erwartungen werden gebrochen. Und jetzt alle. Erwartungen werden gebrochen. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. So, die Comedy-Schule entwickelt sich prächtig. The National School of Comedy, letzte Woche gegründet, heute schon den ersten Abschlussjahrgang. Und, ich habe eine Nachricht, hat mich ereilt, und zwar gibt es in Deutschland keine Prankster-Schule, aber in New York, da gibt es die Improv Everywhere. Und das wäre in etwa, vielen Dank übrigens an Jakob, der hat geschrieben, Improv Everywhere ist in etwa das, was wir suchen. Das waren doch die, ähm, genau. Nee, warte, wie heißt nochmal diese Aktion, wo alle danach wieder weglaufen?
Flashmobs.
Flashmobs, genau, Flashmobs.
Echt, so weit ist mit Flashmobs schon, dass sie nicht mehr nur inflational erwähnt werden,
sondern mittlerweile gar nicht mehr erwähnt werden, dass du sogar den Namen vergisst?
Da sind Flashmobs mittlerweile?
Da muss ich mich aber echt an Dimitri Martin hängen, der mit einem Tweet, das perfekt gesagt hat,
der sowas geschrieben hat, sinngemäß sowas wie, interessant, wie Flashmob so schnell erschienen und wieder verschwunden wird. Also, perfekter Tweet einfach. Einer dieser Tweets, die man sich einrahmen kann einfach. Hier zum Beispiel, ehrlich gesagt, ich fände man gut, wenn wir mal sowas wie Aktionskunst machen würden, wie Improv Everywhere auch. Ein Fake-Apple-Store aufmachen. Zum Beispiel. Oder, ich fände gut, das wäre mal eine sehr aufwendige Aktion, schau mal, aber gut. Weißt du, wer mir fehlt? Christoph Schlingensieb, so jemand fehlt mir. Dass wir mal so lustige Aktionen machen, wo wir der Gesellschaft zeigen, wo der Hammer hängt. Ach so, den Hammer vorhalten und den Spiegel runterreissen von der Maske. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Hast du irgendeine Idee? Nein. Ja, gut, dann lassen wir es. Ja, aber ich denke mir nur ... Erster Tag in unserem neuen Aktions-Klubs-Club. Weißt du, der erste Tag ist ja auch der, wo man erst mal ankommt in der neuen Filiale. Dann das Whiteboard aufhängt, das noch, wo die Folie abkratzt. Dieser klassische Folientag. Den Rest deines Lebens hast du jeden Tag den ersten Tag einer neuen Firma. Man kommt an, man packt die Stühle aus, man schraubt sie zusammen, das Whiteboard, man darf die Folie abziehen. Ja, die Folie abziehen und dann bleibt die immer klemmen. Das ist wirklich, nein, das ist nervig. Nein, die Folie abziehen? Super befriedigend, toll, aber es ist nicht diese Folie, die einfach im Ratsch abgeht. Es ist die, wo man knibbeln muss. Und zwar richtig knibbeln muss. Und dann bleibt die in den Ecken. Hier hängt leider keins gerade zur Veranschaulichung. Die hängt in den Ecken. Die kriegst du nicht komplett raus. Viele Whiteboards haben das immer noch. Untersucht eure Whiteboards genau. Und damit meine ich genau. Schaut in die Ecken. Und ihr werdet sehen, da sind noch so kleine Folienüberresteste und die machen einen wahnsinnig. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich habe mir für meine neue Wohnung von so einem Gastrobedarf, so einen Edelstahl-Gastrowagen gekauft. Der dient so ein bisschen als Kücheninsel, ist ganz schick eigentlich. Der war aber so einfoliert, dass ich die Folie nicht komplett abbekommen habe. Da hängt immer noch sehr viel Folie, sichtbar dran. Ich kriege das nicht ab, das ist ein Tag lang Arbeit.
Dann habe ich den geschrieben und dann habe ich mittlerweile sehr viel
Rabatt bekommen, weil diese Folie
quasi, und dann denke ich mir,
das macht ja doch immer so. Ist das gerade
ein besonderes Modell, was ich bekommen habe? Ist das ein Modell,
wo das jetzt fehlerhaft ist oder nicht?
Oder macht das immer so aus?
Aber ja, aber ist das nicht mal ein Tag,
der sich lohnen würde, mal so hinsetzen mit einer schönen
Kassette TKKG und dann einfach nur abfolieren? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr. Mal schön die Folie runterreißen? Ich muss ganz kurz mal hier auf die Dreher gucken, weil du bist wesentlich lauter als ich. Och, das war wieder das Problem. Aber jetzt, guck mal, jetzt schau mal hier. Ich dreh da nicht dran. Aber da wurde gedreht. Ich dreh. Jede Woche Stefan Tietze. Ich dreh nicht. Ich hab eine kräftigere St. Jede Woche, Stefan Tietzem. Du wirkst schwach, du wirkst kränklich. Ich drehe nicht, ich schwöre dir, ich drehe nicht dran. Au. Aber ich bin gerade auch in so einem Detektivmodus, ehrlich gesagt. Und zwar, bei uns am Haus sind Fahrraddiebe. Pfff, und sie sind Thema. Also hast du dich verkleidet als Fahrer mit einer GoPro auf dem Kopf?
Mit so einem Camouflage-Bundeswehr-Autfeld habe ich mich in Gebüsch gehockt und bin aufgefloten, weil mein Handy auf Lautfahrt war.
Du wurdest geklaut. Ich wurde geklaut. So, aber dann im Wagen. Ich habe tatsächlich Diebe gestellt.
Zunächst fing es ganz normal an, die Woche, und mal wieder war ein Fahrrad weg. Einisschen angsteinflössend, weil ich schlafe quasi einigermaßen mit Blick auf diesen Fahrradständer und wache auch nachts regelmäßig auf und dann aber schnell wieder ein, weil ich gut schlafe. Und dann waren Nachbarn irgendwann sauer, weil die ganze Nacht Räder verschwunden sind. Wie kriegst du das mit, dass die Fahrräder verschwinden? Oder verschwindet immer deins? Nee, Fahrräder verschwinden und es wird in der WhatsApp-Gruppe heiß diskutiert. Mit vielen schimpfenden Smileys. Das Haus ist gut vernetzt. So, und dann war es ein großes Thema und irgendwann dachte ich, das kann nicht sein. Und dann habe ich, wie es der Zufall wollte, für meinen Briefkasten ein Schild angebracht. So, dann sah ich da zwei Jungs, die waren so 16. Und dann standen die da rum und haben die Fahrräder beobachtet. Und dann habe ich so getan, als würde ich sehr lange brauchen, diesen Sticker. Ich habe mit so einer Labelmaschine, da habe ich mir meinen Namen drauf gemacht, damit ich einfach, ich bin zu faul für so ein Klingelschild, da muss es im richtigen Format ausdrucken, keinen Bock gab.
Also habe ich mir so eine Labelmaschine gekauft, mit meinem Namen da reingepresst und dann aufgeklebt. Und das ist eine Sache von zwei Sekunden. Aber ich wollte ja wissen, ob die das vielleicht sind, die die Fahrräder immer klauen. Also habe ich ganz lange gebraucht und dann getan und dann riss du den Klebestreifen hinten nicht ab. Ach Gott. Aber ein bisschen overacted auch, oder? Total overacted. Och, och, ich habe für die letzte Reihe gespielt, also will ich für die allerletzte Reihe, mit grossen Augen, viel Augenbraun und Schweiß. Der ganze Körper war involviert. Anklagende Geste. Und dann ist er mir runtergefallen, dann habe ich die Arme in die Luft geworfen und nach unten. Und dann ging es so weiter ein bisschen, bis die irgendwann gesagt haben, na komm, wir gehen. Und dann haben die das Schauspielbord und sind dann einfach gegangen. Applaudiert, standing ovations und dann gegangen. Aber die sind in die falsche Richtung abgegangen, weil da ging es nicht weiter. Ich wusste also, die liegen noch auf der Lauer. Dann bin ich wieder hochgegangen, um denen das Gefühl zu geben, als wäre jetzt die Luft rein, als wäre die Vorstellung beendet. Laut Pfeifen bist bis du das Treffen haushochgegibst. Lalalala, ich gehe jetzt ganz normal zurück. Ich lege mich ins Schlafen, bin ich müde. Ich lege mich jetzt hin. Gehe also hoch, mit grossen flamboyanten Schritten, immer diese Banane, die du mir auch beigebracht hast, immer die Banane gehen, nie gerade Wege gehen, mit grossen Gesten, schließe ich auf, geh, warte da zwei Minuten, mit dem Gesicht an der Fensterscheibe gepresst, um herauszugucken. Und dann habe ich zwei Minuten gewartet, bin wieder rausgegangen und habe schon auf der Treppe gemerkt, was höre ich denn da? Hör ich metallene Geräusche und dann beginnt schon der Kopf zu rattern. Wie begegnet man denn jetzt? Sind die bewaffnet? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Bin ich bewaffnet? Bin ich bewaffnet? Nein. Also bin ich hängengegangen und dann waren die tatsächlich an dem Fahrrad. Und was mich schockiert hat, ich habe gesagt, Entschuldigung, kann ich euch helfen? Das war mein Opener. Kann ich euch irgendwie helfen? Und dann hat er nicht aufgehört. Und das fand ich mich ein bisschen beleidigend, fand ich das von ihm, weil ich bin ja schon eine imposante Gestalt, also gross. Ja, aber nur weil du gross bist, bist du nicht imposant. Also das sind immer zwei verschiedene. Imposante Erscheinungen. Dann habe ich gesagt, Entschuldigung, kann ich euch helfen? Und er hat nicht aufgehört, das Fahrrad zu klauen. Also er war nicht, er hat den Prozess nicht gestoppt. Aber es waren zwei.
Es waren zwei. Einer stand Palir, Paschir, Parade.
Einer stand, wie heißt das?
Schmiere.
Schmier, nee, ja, vielleicht.
Spalier, aber das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Aber ja, okay.
Aber das wollte ich.
Ausguck.
Und dann hat der eine dann irgendwann mal gesagt,
du kannst das Fahrrad nicht klauen.
Er hat gesagt, das ist mein Fahrrad,
Ich bin ein sehr gut Schritt, das gegangen und gejoggt. Und ich habe hinterhergerufen, ihr haut jetzt sofort ab, sonst hol ich die Polizei. Ohne mich zu verhaspeln. Wirklich? I delivered it. Genailed, aber tief Luft geholt. Tief Luft geholt, viel zu nervös, viel zu laut gesagt. Nee, ich habe tatsächlich mit einer klaren, imposanten Stimme gesagt, jetzt verschwindet oder ich hole die Polizei. Respekt. Nicht schlecht, Stefan? Ich glaube, ich habe nicht den Flur und den Will. Du bist ja immer ganz schnell am Fotoapparat. Du hast ihn ja quasi immer um den Hals hängen mittlerweile. Du suchst Gesetzesbrecher, um ihn sofort zu fotografieren und der Polizei zu schicken. Habe ich jetzt nicht gemacht zum Beispiel. Hätte ich ja fotografieren können. Ich bewundere deinen Mut. Ich will aber auch angemerkt haben, dass man das hätte besser machen können.
Was hätte ich machen können? Also ich hätte, glaube ich, ein Foto gemacht, es ausgedruckt, eine Sicherheitskopie davon behalten und denen ein Foto mitgegeben im Sinne von ich habe was gegen euch in der Hand. Du glaubst, dass du in der Zeit, wo die deinen Fahrrad klauen, hättest du runtergehen können, Foto gemacht, wieder hoch, dich erstmal an Photoshop gesetzt, dann Helligkeit gerade ziehen, Gradationskurven, man kennt den Scheiß, Druck gedruckt, die Scheiße, ausgedruckt, inhandgenommen, laminiert, zusammengefaltet in den Umschlag, Lippenstift aufgetragen, Kussmund auf den Umschlag, damit da so die Lippen abgedrückt sind. So, Lippenstift wieder abnehmen. Weil sonst peinlich. Weil sonst merkwürdig. Ganz wichtig. Dann zu den hingegangenen Rettungen, ah, ihr sucht bestimmt das hier. Hä? Dann hätte ich ihnen einen Brief gegeben mit einem Umschlag und dann wäre ich
wieder gegangen. Und in dem Umschlag
ist einfach nur,
klappen die auf, die nach vier,
das Foto von denen, wie sie das...
So ein aufwendiges, so eine Faltkunst.
Wenn man das so aufmacht, das kommt so eine Ritterburg
hoch und dann sind die verwirrt.
Und das kannst du nutzen, um denen auf den Kehlkopf zu hauen.
Genau. Während die den Lesenden aufklappen, schleichst du die von hinten an. Und haust die mit dem Karate-Move gegen den Kehlkopf. Aber beiden gleichzeitig. Ein mit der rechten Hand, ein mit der linken Hand, einfach batz. Beide fallen tot um. Du schaufelst einen Grab, beerdigst die sofort, und dann kannst du mal schauen, wie die gucken. Und wenn du das richtig gut einstellst, kannst du sogar noch das Fahrrad klauen, was die geklaut hätten.
Genau, das halb geöffnete Schloss. Und sollten sie aber durch den Kehlkopfschlag nicht direkt ausgeschaltet sein,
würde ich auf das Foto von denen, wie sie das Fahrrad klauen, hinten noch mit einem Edding draufschreiben.
Tim.
Bei Fragen, Doppelpunkt, 0800 0800 hab euch und eine Ausrufe zeigen. Okay. Okay? Und das ist eine Ansage. Das ist meine Ansage an die Kriminalität. Ich habe zwei 16-Jährige umgebracht, mit Hilfe eines Ritterburg-Faltpapiers. Ja. Werbung. Ey, Stefan, was würde ich dafür geben, wenn ich mich einfach mit Ernährung nicht mehr auseinandersetzen müsste? Wenn man einfach einen Löffel von einer magischen Substanz nehmen könnte und damit sozusagen alle Vitamine für den Tag hätte. Du, der Mensch braucht 75 essentielle Vitamine und Nährstoffe, um irgendwie halbwegs gut zu funktionieren. Glaubst du, ich habe die Nerven, mir zu gucken, wo ich meine 75 Vitamine und Mineralien zusammenkriege? Nein, das wäre ja gut für deine Leistungsfähigkeit, für dein fucking Immunsystem, für deinen Energiehaushalt und für deine Darmgesundheit. Weißt du, glaube ich, was wir brauchen? Athletic Greens! Athletic Greens ist nämlich der Morgendrink für euch, den ihr einmal pro Tag zu euch nehmt. Und dann müsst ihr euch um diesen ganzen Quatsch keine Sorgen mehr machen, weil da ist alles drin, was ihr braucht. Euer Energielevel wird erhöht und ihr kommt einfach topmotiviert und energetisch durch den Tag. Das sagen sogar Profisportler. Und wenn die das sagen, call me in. Und das Beste ist, wie immer haben wir natürlich einen kleinen Schmankerl für euch. Geht einfach auf athleticgreens.com slash ufo und findet da ein Angebot. Und nicht nur irgendeins. Denn wenn ihr Athletic Greens abonniert, bekommt ihr auch noch obendrauf ein Fläschchen. Das ist ein Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3. Und gerade in der kalten Jahreszeit, wo es keine Sonne gibt, braucht ihr Vitamin D3. Nicht nur ihr, auch ich, aber selbst Florentin. Ja, ihr müsst nie wieder in die Sonne. Und ein Schmankerl selbst ist aber Athletic Greens auch, denn es schmeckt gut, hat weniger als ein Gramm Zucker und ist für jede Ernährungsform geeignet, also auch vegan, Keto, Paleo, was auch immer ihr macht, lässt sich das gut integrieren. Werbung. Ja, du hast schon recht, also man hätte ein bisschen kreativer sein können, aber dann ist man auch nervös in so einer Situation. Man weiß nicht, haben die ein Messer vielleicht, gehen die jetzt auf dich los. Hä, warum grinst du so? Das sind Fahrraddiebe, das ist kein Kavaliersdelikt. Du hättest ja auch ein Messer mitnehmen können. Das wollte ich mir schon mal sagen. Das wollte ich mir schon mal ernsthaft sagen, das ist kein Kavaliersdelikt. Ehrlich gesagt, es gibt so manche Phrases, wo ich mich frage, wann sagst du mir zum ersten Mal ernsthaft. Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben, das ist kein Kavaliersdelikt gesagt, und ich glaube, ich werde es auch erstmal nicht sagen. Ich glaube, jeder Mensch hat so zehn Phrasen, aber auch nicht mehr. Und die meisten Phrasen hat man nicht. Also jeder hat so zehn Phrasenslots und jeder hat aber andere zehn Phrasen. Wie so ein Magic Deck. Genau, wie so ein Magic Deck. Und andere benutzt man aber einfach nicht. Also sowas wie, da wird doch der Hund in der Pfanne verrückt. Ist nicht in meinem Repertoire. Aber es gibt Leute, die haben das in ihrem Repertoire. Und ich glaube, man kann da wirklich das ganz systematisch aufstellen, welche zehn Phrasen jeder von jeder Mensch hat. Und die meisten hat man ja nicht. Ich habe nicht mal, ich glaube, ich spinne. Nee? Nee. Was ich habe, und ich bin nicht stolz drauf, würde ich gerne tauschen, ist, der hat doch nicht alle Tassen im Schrank. Würdest du gerne tauschen gegen was? Ich glaube, ich spinne. Also falls ihr da draußen, ich spinne habt und Interesse hat, mit Stefan zu tauschen, der hat doch nicht alle Tassen im Schrank. Ich habe viele doppelt, ehrlich gesagt. Was ich doppelt habe, zum Beispiel, ich bin noch nicht bescheuert, so etwas habe ich doppelt. Achtmal. Also könnt ihr gerne tauschen, ruft Stefan ab, ihr trefft euch nachts in der alten Mühle und könnt euch da austauschen. Was meine Mutter hat, ist, das macht mich Mischugge. Mischugge? Mischugge, jiddisch, finde ich toll, hätte ich gern. Ja, ja. Ich nehme mir das vor, so eine glitzernde Karte. Capiche? Capiche? Capiche? Habe ich auch nicht. Das ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, einer der ersten Momente, wo ich versucht habe, einen Gag zu machen in meinem Leben. Und zwar war das noch in der Grundschule. Und ich habe immer mit meinem Bruder Simpsons geschaut, aber das meiste nicht verstanden. Trotzdem lauter als gelacht. Lauter als gelacht, die sind gelb. Genial. Und da gibt es eine Szene, wo irgendjemand was zu Bart sagt, irgendein Erwachsener redet mit Bart und sagt, nein, nein, nein, hast du... und dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hier, du kannst hier nicht mehr herkommen, kapische? Und Bart sagt... Oh mein Gott. Warte, warte, warte. Der Erwachsene sagt, du kannst hier nicht mehr herkommen, kapische? Und Bart sagt, alles ausser kapische. Okay? Haben wir uns? Sind wir da? Du hast noch diesen bunten drehenden Beachball im Gesicht gerade. Okay, du hast jetzt zehn Minuten Zeit, mir Fragen zu stellen. Dann machen wir aber weiter. Was bedrückt dich gerade? Alles ausser Kapit... Ich verstehe den Witz nicht. Naja, Kapitze heißt so viel wie, hast du verstanden? Und er sagt, ich habe alles verstanden, ausser Kapitze. Was natürlich unkirklich ist... Was ein Gag ist, weil er es verstanden hat. Guck mal, jetzt bist du doch schon da. Guck mal, ich bin am Ziel. Geht doch. Ich bin am Ziel, ich wurde aber hingetragen. Und genau den gleichen Gag habe ich auch mal gemacht, weil in der Schule die Lehrerin mit mir gesprochen hat und die hat irgendwas gesagt, hier mach das mal bis morgen, kapische? Und ich so, jetzt ist mein Moment und der Himmel tut sich auf und die Ecke lächeln mich an. Und du hast sofort gesagt, alles ausser Verstand. Und sie so, hä? Und alle so, what? Und du so, fuck. Ich bin mit meinem Skateboard aus dem Klassenzimmer rausgefahren. Und ein Auto kam direkt. Ein Uranstab kam mir in die Tasche geflogen. Es war eine weirde Welt damals, es war eine weirde Zeit damals. Aber den habe ich genauso gemacht. Hä, die geht nicht. habe auch gesagt, alles außer Kapische und sie so, ja. Okay. Naja. Kapische? Das ist vielleicht was. Aber hat irgendwer gelacht? Nee. Hat sie gelacht? Nee, es gibt ja Möglichkeiten, den Gag anzunehmen, ohne ihn zu würdigen. Also so. Also ich habe es verstanden, ich möchte dir aber explizit mitteilen, dass ich es nicht lustig finde. Dass ich es gar nicht lustig finde. Also einfach nur so, naja, naja, ja, so war es in der Richtung. Aber das heißt, der erste Versuch, einen Gag zu machen, war, ihn einfach zu klauen. Richtig. Okay. Richtig. Und einmal natürlich, als ich in der Schule We Are The Champignons gesungen habe, das war ein Riesenlacher. Das war aber unser allererster Gag, würde ich behaupten. Und auch mittlerweile nicht mehr im Repertoire. Nee, er hat aus seinem Programm geworfen. Sehr früh sogar. Ich glaube, noch dem ersten Mal und dann hat nicht funktioniert und dann direkt kommen. Ja, schade, würde ich gerne bei dir nochmal sehen, ehrlich gesagt. Also das sind so ein paar Oldtimer. Aber das ist wichtig Oldtimer. Du weigerst dich aber auch, die Klassiker zu spielen,
habe ich manchmal das Gefühl.
Du willst immer nur die neue Platte, das neue Album.
Ja, ich will so ein originelles Deck spielen,
wo man gerne zuguckt und so, aber nicht genau versteht, was da passiert.
Ja.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, es ist, glaube ich, ein guter Ansatz,
den man den Leuten mal auf den Weg geben kann.
Ihr könnt nicht einfach was Neues sagen. Nee. Also so einfach ist das halt einfach nicht, weil das merkt man sofort. Das ist so, wie wenn du einen Hut plötzlich trägst. Du trägst den Hut und dann ist es aber so, man hat einen gewissen Zeitraum, demjenigen zu sagen, lass uns mit dem Hut, ab einem gewissen Punkt kann man es nicht mehr sagen. So ein Einlog, wer wird Werbemillionär. Erstmal ist es gelb. Genau, es ist erstmal gelb. Es ist erstmal gelb und dann ist es so ein... Und Günther Jauch hat aber noch die Macht, in die richtige Richtung zu drehen. Oder in die Werbung zu gehen, was in beiden Fällen die bessere Idee wäre. Eine gute Idee wäre. Und wenn jemand in eurem Bekanntenkreis anfängt, einen Hut zu tragen, denkt euch, das ist jetzt noch orange. Ihr seid Günther Jauch, ihr könnt jetzt noch sagen, bist du dir wirklich sicher? Möchtest du wirklich Hut einloggen? Ich gebe Ihnen jetzt noch mal die Chance, Ihre Antwort zu ändern. Sie möchten wirklich bei Hut bleiben. So kann man immer noch ein bisschen arbeiten. A, Hut. B, Weste. Oh Gott, wenn das auch Gott. Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken. C, ein ganz dicker Gürtel. D, ganz jahres kurze Hose. Oh Gott. Gut, vielleicht können wir doch nochmal zurück zu A, zu Hut. Vielleicht wäre das eine Chance. Es gibt Leute, deren Style ist eine ganz jahreskurze Hose. Ja, habe ich aber auch nicht viel dagegen. Habe ich nicht viel dagegen. Ich war tatsächlich auch lange so ein kurzer Hosentyp. Also der klassische Opener bei mir war immer, ist dir nicht kalt? Hunden habe ich das ganze Jahr gehört, ständig. Und was war am Ende deine ausgefeierte Comebackline? Nein, nein. Ich habe mir tatsächlich lange überlegt, was man darauf antworten kann. Und ich glaube, ich habe die perfekte Antwort gefunden. Und zwar, kannst du mal kurz durchspielen, also ich sitze da irgendwie im Schnee, kurze Hose, dann kommst du auf mich zu. Ist der nicht kalt? Nee. Und das reicht dann auch. Okay, ja. Das reicht dann auch, dann einfach zu sagen ... Wie bei mir zum Beispiel, spielst du Basketball? Oder alternativ dazu, wie ist die Luft da oben? Ja. Ja. Aber gibt es da auch ein klassisches Comeback drauf? Wie ist die Luft da oben? Nein. Keine Chance. Ja, es ist schwierig, aber ich glaube ... Nee, oder so ein ... Was? Ich kann dich nicht um ... Super. Ist dir das jetzt gerade eingefallen? Ich kann dich hier oben nicht hören. Nee, bestimmt schon mal gebraucht. Wirklich? Und das Beste eigentlich nach, spielst du ja nicht Basketball, wäre so ein Ja, und dann dreht man sich um und wirft Dreier. Aber das ist noch nie passiert. Mit ihm. Die Person, die das gefragt hat, nimmt man und wirft sie in den nächsten Basketballkorb. In den nächsten, die umliegenden Basketballkorb. Aber mit so einem Sprungwurf oder so einem normalen Wurf? Ne, so einem lässigen. Aber die Hand muss oben so abknicken. Ja, das ist das Beste. Das ist mein Basketball, die Hand, die dann so umknickt, nachdem der Ball weg ist. Oder wenn man beim Golf geschlagen hat und dann so diese Endposition und dann nochmal mit der Hand so an die Stirn, 90 Grad Winkel an die Stirn. Es ist Schatten, es regnet, man sieht nichts, die Sonne blendet nicht, trotzdem die Hand an die Stirn,
um in die Ferne gucken zu können.
Ja, finde ich super. Und ich habe
auch mal, mir fallen diese kleinen Sachen vor allem auf.
Ich kann das alles nicht, aber mir
fallen so kleine Details auf, wie zum Beispiel
Handknickt ab und sowas. Wenn ich eine
Sportart beobachte, das heißt immer, wenn ich Basketball
spiele, geht nichts, aber
solche weirden Haltungsnoten,
die will ich mir dann holen.
Ja, oder klassisch Bowling
natürlich auch. Also wirklich
Ich denke, es ist ich mir dann holen. Ja, oder klassisch Bowling natürlich auch. Also wirklich die komplette Bewegung perfekt und dann auch so diese Füsse überkreuzt. Also das, wenn du wirklich so bowlst und dann den hier, ganz weit weg, ganz weit weg. Und am Ende diesen Italiener, am Ende hast du diesen Italiener, der so weggeht. Aber auch übrigens neuer Emoji, kommen wir gleich zu. Und dann aber auch in der Pose verharren. Immer verharren. Wenn du den Boatingball weggeworfen hast, in der Pose verharren. Richtig. So wirklich nach unten. Bisschen wie er es in einen Frisbee geworfen. Ja, aber ich meine, die Boatingkugel fliegt natürlich straight in die Seite. Ja, natürlich, sofort in die Seite. Aber es sieht gut aus. Ja, und wenn es ein bisschen zu flach wäre, würde die auf die andere Bahn gehen, reden wir nicht drüber. Oder alternativ hat man halt die Ränder so hochgeklappt, weil man vorne... Aber warte mal, ist das nicht unser soziales Experiment oder unsere Installationskunst? Wir gehen an eine Bowlingbahn und wir haben wirklich den kompletten Anzug. Wir haben das Team... Habt ihr Handschuhe dabei? Wir haben den Handschuh, wir haben eigene Schuhe,
wir haben eine Bowlingkugel mit unserem Gesicht drauf, wir haben ein eigenes
Tuch und gehen dann mit perfekter
Form und Körperspannung
an die Bowlingbahn und pfeffern
zehn Kugeln mit voller Wucht
in die Seitenlinie. Und gehen dann
stolz zurück
und grüssen den Mann vorne an der Kasse
mit dem Vornamen.
Mit Vornamen, nach jedem
Vielen Dank. Gehen stolz zurück und grüssen den Mann vorne an der Kasse mit dem Vornamen.
Mit Vornamen, nach jedem Wurf schauen wir zufrieden auf das Punktebrett, wo immer Null steht und dann wirklich einmal in die Runde, polieren unsere Kugel, um dann direkt nochmal den Voll in die Seite zu werfen. Ich war noch in Berlin und habe gebowlt mit einem Kumpel und nach jedem einzelnen, nach jedem einzelnen Schlag kamen die nicht drunter mehr. Ich verstehe ähnlich, wie es funktioniert. Niemand versteht das. Dafür, dass es so. Das sind Kinder, eine Horde Kinder sind das. Das ist eine Horde Inder. Alles, was man sich technisch nicht erklären kann, sind eine Horde Kinder, die hinter der Bahn versuchen, die Pinze aufzustellen. Ja, weil da ist es mega seltsam, hat nie ganz funktioniert, immer andere,
wild andere Sachen und so, da muss man auf Knöpfe drücken.
Da kommt dann so ein Toaster raus.
Leute, was ist das? Was ist jetzt los?
Dann drückt man drauf und dann gingen die wieder hoch und dann wieder runter, aber dann zählte
das irgendwie als meinen Wurf
und so und dann
habe ich den Typen von der Bahn geholt,
ist doch die Frage, wie kann man diesen Knopf drücken,
bis du denkst, ja, hier kommen wir
leider nicht weiter, holen einen Typen von der
Bullingbahn, der kam zu uns gelaufen
und Habe ich den Typen von der Bahn geholt, ist doch die Frage, wie auch kann man, kannst du mit dem Knopf drücken, bis du denkst, ja, hier kommen wir leider nicht weiter, holen einen Typen von der Bullingbahn, der kam zu uns gelaufen und ist dann über so einen geheimen Weg zwischen den Bahnen lang in so einer, wie so einem Mini-Quest, Donkey Kong-artiges Level, Bonuslevel, ja. Weird an den Bahnen langgelaufen, durch die Mitte und hinten aber eine Tür in diesen mega trashigen Airbrush-Kunstinstallationen, ist er reingegangen, um dann da hinten in so eine Magical World was zu tun, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist das so eine riesige Schwerölmaschine, die mit Erdöl läuft, die wirklich voller Ruhs ist, wie so ein U-Boot, die einfach so also eine riesige Maschine. Und man sah ihn reingehen und nach links verschwinden.
Da war er dann für so lächerlich lange
zehn Minuten bestimmt.
Und dann kam er zurück und war
so russbeschmiert und
hat so eine tote Katze
in der Hand. Na, da haben wir doch
den Übeltäter.
So ein Kegel, so ein Kegel.
Ja, passiert jede Woche.
Und dann hauen die dir die Katze so vor die Füsse.
Könnt ihr behalten.
Der Witz hat nicht funktioniert, weil ich dachte, Kegel ist die Konkurrenzsportart.
Ach so, aber die sehen gleich aus, Pins und Kegel.
Das ist vielleicht was für die Spezialisten da draußen, die sagen, ihr geht bowlen, Entschuldigung, wir gehen kegeln.
Genau.
Da habe ich ihn gefragt, weil ich das so spannend fand,
was dahinter zu sehen ist, ob ich da vielleicht
mal hingucken könnte, was da so passiert.
Und er hat sich wirklich
umgeguckt und hat gesagt,
naja, vielleicht wenn es hier ein bisschen leerer ist.
Und jetzt
und seitdem
denke ich mir,
was ist dahinter,
bitte?
Er hat sich umgeguckt, ich glaube sogar, er hat eine Kamera gesucht und hat gesagt, Zitat, ja, vielleicht, wenn es ein bisschen leerer ist. Nervös, aber auch leicht nervös. Ja, ja. So, als hätte er Hilfe gebrauchen können bei den Dingen, die sich dahinter abspielen. Ja, und jetzt? Was ist jetzt mit Zahn-B, Adventure. Klassisch, kennt man aus jedem Film. Und da endet die Geschichte normalerweise auch kurz danach. Call to Adventure, aber so in so einem Charlie Kaufman-artigen Film. So einem absurden Film. Ja, wo der Call ganz am Ende erst kommt. Oder so. Wir haben jetzt leider keine Zeit mehr. Hauptfügiger guckt in die Kamera und sagt, wir haben jetzt schon die ganze Wüstengeschichte mit dem Treibsand und der Liane und so, das hatten wir jetzt schon, wir haben jetzt keine Zeit mehr, deswegen machen wir jetzt hier Schluss und vielleicht gibt es einen zweiten Teil, guckt mal, kauft die DVD, dann geht es vielleicht weiter. Ciao! Ich habe keine Ahnung, was dahinter ist. Aber ich finde, das ist eine richtig gute Antwort. Aber vor allem, das ist ja ein Geschäftsmann, der weiß, du kommst auf jeden Fall nochmal. Nein wenig los ist. Das ist ein Azubi, der da sein Geld verdient. Meinst du? Ja, das ist eine Bowlingbahn. Das ist ja auch nicht so wie in den US-Azubi. Das ist ein Ausbildungsbuch. Nein, das ist ein Azubi woanders und macht da einen Nebenjob. 400 Euro. Ja, speziell.
Du hast eine enorme Menschenkenntnis, Stefan, muss man echt mal sagen, dass du all das nur von diesen
kleinen Interaktionen herausgefunden hast.
Das ist auch viel gelogen.
Aber ich kann mir echt vorstellen,
dass da wirklich... Ist das nicht auch
bei den Simpsons so, dass da so eine riesige Fabrik
hinten ist, wo aus einem Baumstamm
dann ein Kegel so gefräst wird
und die alten Kegel werden immer wieder weggeschmissen. Ach, die Simpsons. Die sind schon lustig. Lustig und gelb, genau wie Emojis. Denn, ohne Scheiß, wir haben es geschafft.
Wir haben es geschafft?
Beziehungsweise, nein.
Naja, ihr habt es geschafft.
Aber damit wir.
Aber damit haben es am Ende, wir streichen einen Ruhm ein.
Denn wir haben ja die Reichweite.
Wir dürfen den Pokal auch mal halten.
Thais hat den Pokal bei dir zu Hause. Dann.
Ja, natürlich.
So, denn, wie kriegt man seine Träume in das Smartphone, in die Tastatur, wie wird eine Hoffnung zu einem Emoji?
Und diese Frage ist, dass die Tastatur, wie wird eine Hoffnung zu einem Emoji? Und diese Frage beantwortet uns heute Frederik. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer Spezialausgabe des Podcast-Ufos mit mir, Frederik Riedel. Herzlich willkommen auch von mir, mein Name ist Stappertitze, das ist Florentin Will. Dankeschön, hallo. Ja, und herzlich willkommen zum... Das Podcast-Ufo-Emoji-Projekt. Ja, erstmal vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich bin heute hier, weil ihr in Folge 111 des Podcast-Ufos damit angefangen habt, eure eigenen Emoji-Ideen beim Unicode-Konsortium einzureichen. Aber im Gegensatz zu euch habe ich es durchgezogen. Ich habe seit sieben Jahren daran gearbeitet, das Eisbär-Emoji Wirklichkeit werden zu lassen. Und nun, mit iOS 14.2 wurde mein Vorschlag umgesetzt und wird ab November auf hunderten Millionen von iPhones installiert. Aber wie ist es dazu gekommen? So, und da fragt man sich natürlich, wie entstehen neue Emojis? Und das ist tatsächlich relativ simpel, die werden einfach gepitcht von normalen Leuten, können da ihren Pitch hinschicken und sagen, hey, aus diesen und jenen Gründen muss es diesen neuen Emoji geben. Ja genau, und das ist das sogenannte Unicode-Konsortium. Das erreicht man unter unicode.org und da kann jeder eigene Vorschläge einreichen. Das ist im Prinzip einfach eine grosse Organisation aller grossen Technikkonzerne mit Hauptsitz in Palo Alto in Kalifornien.
Wie denn neue Emojis entstehen und wie denn Emojis überhaupt gehandhabt werden?
Ja, ich liebe einfach Eisbären und deshalb habe ich mich 2013 dazu entschlossen, ein Proposal einzureichen, habe mir richtig Mühe gegeben, ein mehrseitiges Dokument eingereicht, das eben die Relevanz des Eisbärs darlegt und habe dann einige Jahre später das Ergebnis bekommen. Thank you for your submission, the committee reviewed this today, members noted that this is in our list of animals, but there are other animals with higher priority for addition.
You do not need to do anything further at this time. Wow, es ist möglich, sich selbst in der Internetgeschichte zu verebigen.
Es ist total geil, vor allem weil alle benutzen das und es ist ja wirklich wie eine eigene Buchstabe zu erfinden so.
Nur halt, dass der, auch ein Bild sagt ja auch mehr als tausend Worte.
Du kannst ja sozusagen eine Kultur beeinflussen mit.
Wer hat das F erfunden? Das sind Legenden. Das K. Alter!
Die Auberginne. Was für ein krankes Schwein hat die Auberginne erfunden?
Holy shit.
Und die Kultur beeinflusst.
Die Antwort des Unicode-Konsortiums brachte mich dann aber auf die Idee,
es war ja nicht das Eisbär-Emoji selber, was diese Reaktion hervorgebracht hat,
sondern es waren die Voting-berechtigten Mitglieder des Unicode-Konsortiums. Das Tolle ist ja, jeder könnte hier theoretisch Mitglied werden. Für eine Position als Voting-Member kostet das allerdings 20.000 Dollar pro Jahr. Das war mir aber dann ein bisschen zu teuer, um an den Entscheidungsmeetings teilzunehmen. Das sind dann Firmen wie Apple, Adobe, Netflix oder SAP. Aber kein Problem, habe ich mir gedacht, es gibt ja das Internet. Und da es insgesamt nur eine Handvoll votingberechtigter Organisationen gibt, die jeweils einen Repräsentanten zu den VotingmeMeetings schicken, habe ich einfach kurzum Lobbyarbeit geleistet für das Eisbe-Emoji. Man kann sich sehr denken, so einen prestigeträchtigen Titel wie Unicode Voting Member, den gibt man gerne an als Mitarbeiter, beispielsweise auf LinkedIn. Und das habe ich dann einfach gemacht. Ich habe nach Unicode Voting Member auf LinkedIn gesucht und habe die einzelnen Mitglieder im persönlichen Gespräch vom Eisbären überzeugt. Das war 2019. Ja, und was soll ich sagen? Es ist 2020 und jetzt in den nächsten Wochen wird iOS 14.2 released und das enthält dann das Ice-Bare-Emoji für jeden zur Benutzung auf hunderten Millionen von Geräten. Wow, Frederik, you made it. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, richtig gute Idee, auch die Lobbyarbeit, also die Leute direkt anzuschreiben und ich glaube, wir können nie wieder den Ice-Bär-Emoji verwenden, ohne an dich zu denken. Toi, toi, toi, dass der Ice-Bär-Emoji nicht irgendwie sinnbildlich wird für irgendwas wie der Auberginen-Emoji oder sonstige schmutzige Emojis. Ja, man will nicht, ja, schön auf Worten. Du willst nicht zum Organ-Emoji werden, irgendwie das Ice-Bär irgendwie durch irgendein Wort, dass es ähnlich klingt wie irgendwas. Das ist auch nicht so farfetched, dass jetzt der Eisbär zu so einem White Supremacy, weil es gibt ja schon den Braunbär. Pepe ist endlich frei und jetzt kommt der Eisbär-Emoji und wir alle machen dann den Zahn-Emoji. Wisst ihr, wenn ich meine, wenn jetzt plötzlich der Eisbär-Emoji zum White Supremacy-Ding wird. Und dann gibt es eine Doku, Finding Frederick,
irgendwie das kranke Schwein,
das die White Supremacy-Symbol
entdeckt hat. Und der Eisbär
gerät nochmal richtig in Verruf. Und dann werden
extra alle Eisbären getötet.
Wobei er auch nicht verraten hat, was seine Argumente
waren für den Eisbären. Ja, würde mich auch
interessieren, aber er hat es zumindest geschafft,
es durchzuboxen. Es ist ein bisschen vage geblieben.
Man weiß nicht, aus welchen Gründen. Vielleicht waren die Gründe auch nicht so ganz gut. Ich glaube, ein Gegenargument war, lohnt sich das überhaupt noch? Wie, dann gibt es die noch zwei, drei Jahre, dann sind die weg, lohnt sich das überhaupt noch? Aber gut, es gibt auch Dinosaurier-Mojis, von daher, Tiere werden ja berühmter, je länger sie ausgestorben sind eigentlich. Völlig richtig. Ich finde es gut, aber jetzt hast du dir halt einfach ein Tier ausgesucht. Wie gesagt, ich finde es toll. Es ist ein gutes Tier. Es ist super, es ist ein gutes Tier. Es ist auch ein Tier, finde ich, was jetzt in der Klimathematik mit Sicherheit einfach einen schnell zugänglichen Emoji braucht. Aber wir sind ja Freunde der Abstraktion. So, tja, jetzt kommst du mit deinem Geh aus der Tür raus. Wenn du noch einmal Männchen geht aus der Tür raus pitchst.
Nein, doch, ich bin raus. Als Verabschiedung. Du kannst die Tür machen und du kannst den Rausgeher machen. Niemand macht den Doppel-Emoji, niemand macht die Kombi. Doppel-Emoji, klassischer Doppel-Emoji. Ich bin immer noch für den Pokerchip, den gibt es immer noch nicht. Es sind hunderte hinzugekommen, unter anderem ja der, und da wäre ich auch sehr stolz drauf,
wenn ich ihn beigetragen hätte,
den Brille- und Schnurrbart-Emoji.
Wo man nicht genau weiß, wann man den einsetzt.
Ja, aber ich finde die Richtung
gut. Was ich gut fände, wäre zum Beispiel
die Hälfte des Bilds
ist zum Beispiel eine Wand
und dahinter guckt ein Emoji
vor. Oder den mit den Händen,
der so über die Mauer guckt. Oder den Händen mit dem, aber den gibt es ja schon, glaube ich. Echt? Okay. Oder? Weit nicht. Guck mal, es sind aber mittlerweile auch echt zu viele Emojis. Man kennt die gar nicht mehr. Es gibt kaum Emojis, wirklich. Im Vergleich dazu, wie viele jensische Schriftzeichen es gibt, gibt es irgendwie eine Millionstel davon. Lass uns den Trend mal umdrehen. Lass uns mal Massensam uns nicht sagen, wir pitchen, um neu hinzuzufügen, sondern wir pitchen, um alte zu entfernen. Wir machen Big Brother quasi, wir können sie rauswählen. Genau, ruft an. Genau, für das Emoji, für das am wenigsten Leute anrufen, fliegt jedes Jahr raus. Die untersten Szenen, genau so viele wie neu hinzugefügt werden. Und wollen all den Eisbären retten und vergessen, für den klassischen Grinse-Emoji abzustimmen. Und dann fliegt der raus. Das rote Herz, ciao! Das würde 2020 noch vollenden, wenn der Smile-Emoji, wir brauchen ihn nicht mehr. Nee. Wir brauchen ihn einfach nicht. Ich meine, die haben doch Daten. Die wissen doch, welche Emojis verwendet werden. Am wenigsten verwendet werden, ja. Die können doch einfach jedes Jahr die 20, die am wenigsten verwendet werden, rausschmeißen.
Das ist doch ganz leicht.
Ich meine, bitte, wir leben in die späteren. Ich finde gut, dass wir das Spiel, in dem wir nicht gewinnen können, ändern.
Genau, ja.
If you can win the game, change the game.
Change the game.
Change the rules for the game.
If you want to...
If you want to make it here, you can make it everywhere or change the game.
Or change the city.
Kann man nicht alle Sprichwörter zusammen durch ein paar clever gesetzte Kommata, kann man eigentlich don't worry, be happy or change the game. Don't hate the player, hate the game and or change it. Change yourself, don't drag yourself. War ein langes Zitat. Das ist gar nicht so dumm, als Wandtattoo so ein Zitat, so die zehn beliebtesten Zitate in sich vereinigt. Gibt es denn alle Ausdrücke schon? Wer anderen im Glashaus eine Grube gräbt und dabei in den Wald hineinruft, der lässt die Kirche doch mal bitte unterm Teppich. Der lässt bitte die Kirche unterm Teppich. Das als T-Shirt-Spruch, Millionen-Dollar-Idee. Und das als, das trägt ein Emoji, trägt das Shirt.
Genau.
Das ist mein Pitch.
Ja, und das auf dem T-Shirt.
Und auch so das Zitat mit, und das auf dem T-Shirt steht auch dabei.
Das alles auf einer Tasse, auf einem Emoji, auf einem T-Shirt, auf einer Tasse.
Let's go.
Podcast-Ufo-Shop. Und jetzt brasse. Let's go. Podcast UFO Shop.
Und jetzt bräuchten wir so eine Montage, wo so die Lastwagen fahren.
Und dann irgendwie so eine Miene oder sowas und Leute Sachen in den Karton packen und so.
Zu so geiler Rock'n'Roll Musik, so Route 66 Musik.
Und wir... Geil.
Und dann kein Verkauf.
Aber die Musik bleibt High Energy, aber man sieht, wie ich kein Geld mehr habe. Ich habe kein Geld mehr, ich gucke dich immer an, weine, du nimmst mich in den Arm. Wie sagen wir es unseren Eltern, wie sagen wir es unseren Partnerinnen. Wir schlafen mit dem Car to go, wir müssen unsere Wohnung verkaufen. Du hast schon so einen ganz grossen Beharrt, du hast noch Augenringe, ganz tolle Augenringe. Bei mir entwickelt sich eine weirde Krankheit im Gesicht. Können wir das helfen? Ich glaube, es ist Krebs. Du rührst mich ins Krankenhaus. Der Arzt kommt so Kopfschütteln raus, langsam. Du weinst, weinst. Ich komme dahinter, nackter Arsch, aber so ein Kittel an. Und du sagst, what the fuck? Ich meine, wir hatten Geld, uns fucking Satisfaction zu lizenzieren also haben wir den Song auch eingesetzt war er zu lang zu hören vielleicht aber es ist eine gute Montage aber ja, macht das, haut es raus verkauft eure T-Shirts, wir haben dagegen nichts und es gibt schon UFO-Emoji, ne? Gibt's nicht noch irgendwas,
wo wir irgendwo sagen können, eher sowas Maulwurfiges?
Ein Maulwurf. Können wir nicht echt einfach den Maulwurf-Emoji machen? Ja, der sagt auch
sowas wie, ich bin weg, also weil er
so wie, wie hieß das
Pokémon nochmal? Ditto, nein.
Diddle, nee, Ding-o,
Dotti, nee, Ditto,
nee, Diktor, Drogi,
Drogi, Drogi, das Pokémon mit dem komischen Augenringen und dem Stichwunden.
Schuldi, das Pokémon mit dem Schuldenberg.
Irgendwie finde ich die neuen Editionen Pokémon ein bisschen rumiert.
Pokémon so sehr komisch belehrend.
Ja, Heroino, der ganz schlechte Werte hat. Harzi. Harzi, wo du immer Geld zahlen musst, wenn du das Pokémon im Team hast. Okay, finde ich eine gute Idee. Aber ganz kurz noch an, Frederik, eine Sache. Ich wäre sehr enttäuscht, wenn jetzt das Eisbär-Emoji kommt und es ist einfach nur ein Eisbär im Profil. Das nervt mich. Nimm doch die Tiere und versuch mal, es mit denen auszudrücken, weil Emojis sind ja Ausdruck. Das heißt, mach doch irgendwie keine Ahnung, den Eisbären auf so einer schiefen Eisscholle, wie er so, wow, ich rutsche hier runter. Dann könnte man zum Beispiel den Eisbären immer machen als dünnes Eis. Ich habe den gerade geschickt. Wie? Ich habe dir gerade den Eisbären geschickt. Du hast mir eine Schneeflocke und einen Braunbären zusammengeschickt. Nein, du hast mir einen Braunbären und eine Wolke geschickt. Ich finde, die Wolke sieht fast so aus wie der Eisbär. Aber netter Versuch, aber ich habe den Eisbären geschickt. Nein, hast du nicht? Doch. Hast du nicht? Ah, okay. Lustig, dass der Eisbär in Alten... Ich habe noch nicht das Update! Ja, weil ich habe das Update. Ich habe den Eisbären geschickt. Ach, das ist nur das Gesicht? Ja. Aber wie entscheiden die, bei welchem Tier man den ganzen Körper sieht, wie das Krokodil, und bei welchem nur das Gesicht? Oder gibt es beide? Ja, vor allem, welcher Affe, welche zwei Affen haben sich im Trenchcoat in diese Sitzung geschlichen und beschlossen, dass die Affen, es gibt glaube ich sowohl als ganzes Tier gibt, als auch als diese drei super berühmten, wahnsinnig gut platzierten, ich meine sogar ganz woanders als die anderen Tiere, ganz weit vorne platziert, Auge zu, Ohren zu, Mund zu. Welche drei Affen haben sich wirklich da eingeschleust? Welche drei Affen haben 10.000 Dollar zusammengekratzt, um in dieses Emojicon Committee, ein Konsortium ist das das coolste Wort der Welt, es ist ein fucking Konsortium. Aber Aber ich möchte auch mal gerne... Wenn ihr eine Gruppe habt, irgendwie die Roten Wölfe oder sowas, ihr könnt auch einfach das Rote Wolf Konsortium nennen. Alles wird cooler mit dem Wort Konsortium. Lass uns die National School of Comedy streichen und das Comedy Konsortium. Comedy Konsortium. The CCC. The Comedy Konsortium. Das ComCon. ComCon. Guck mal, so klingt auch viel, viel. Comedy Consortium. Das konservative Comedy Consortium. Das ConConCon. Nee, aber ich hoffe wirklich, aber ist es wirklich jetzt nur der Kopf oder was beim Eisbären? Ja, ich mache keine Scherze. At this point. Wem ist da? Das ist der falsche Ort und die falsche Zeit, um Witze zu machen. Aber warum ist es nur der Kopf beim Eisbären? Ich weiß nicht. Da hätte man eine gute Eisnummer machen können. Ja, weil die haben doch auch diese distinctive Form. Die haben das sehr spezielle Improfil, wenn er so rumläuft. So ein hoher Rücken auch. Ja, so ein hohen, also so birnenförmig, nach hinten hin höher. Das sieht doch gut aus. Ich finde, man sollte bei den Tieren immer noch so etwas Charakteristisches reinnehmen, wie zum Beispiel das Krokodil. Super langweilig. Mach doch das Krokodil, wie nur die Augen aus dem Wasser rausgucken. So im Sinne von, ich seh dich oder ich versteck mich oder so, kann man noch was ausdrücken. Mein Eisbär hätte es da auch machen können, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der findet keine Nahrung mehr, der ist hungrig, der reibt sich den Bauch, boah, bin ich müde oder sowas. Der reibt sich dem, was soll der machen, wenn sie müde sind. Ich habe auch wahnsinnig Respekt. Oh, habe ich Kopfschmerzen. Da ist so viel Druck drauf, da ist so viel Druck drauf, dieser ganze Nummer, ey, ohne Scheiß. Also ich will da wieder in einem Konsortium stecken. Ich will generell nicht in einem Konsortium stecken. Das ist eine enorme Verantwortung, ey. Alter, stell dir mal vor, die Verantwortung, die dieses Emoji-Konsortium hat. Es werden ja mittlerweile Kriege geführt, ganze Social-Media-Shitstorm-Wählen, nur durch irgendwie ein Emoji gemacht. Dann irgendwie heißt es jemand, das rote Kreuz steht eigentlich für Hakenkreuz. Nein, tut es nicht, sagt jemand. Ja, woher willst du es wissen? Ich bin im Konsortium. So, es ist schwierig. Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. Sprache wird dadurch definiert, wie es verwendet wird. Ich sag's nochmal. Ich bin in einem Konsortium! Okay, okay, sorry, sorry, sorry. Schwierig eigentlich. Man ist nur auf der Suche danach, es ist irgendwas zu finden. Aber ich glaube, es gibt in diesem Konsortium noch eine eigene Person, die immer checkt, sieht das Emoji aus wie ein Geschlechtsteil. Sind wir uns hundertprozentig sicher? Lass uns doch mal alle Geschlechtsteelle durchgehen. Ich habe hier eine Mappe. Ich habe die Mappe mitgebracht.
Einmal im Jahr kommt dieser schmierige Typ mit seiner Mappe.
Mit seiner klebenden Mappe. Mit seiner verklebten, vergilbten, nicht mehr aufschlagbaren Mappe.
Und die wird intern auch nur die Mappe.
Die Mappe genannt.
Und dann sollen wir nicht noch mal in die Mappe schauen? Und Pedro und Frederik in der letzten Reihe lachen sich kaputt. Weil das sind die Jokester. Die haben den Clown-Emoji hinzugefügt. Ja, das sind diese Bitcoin-Millionärer, die sich einfach aus Scheiss in jedes käufliche Konsortium gesetzt haben. Und es nur noch Konsortium pendeln. Aber ich bin ehrlich, Konsortium klingt für mich auch nach Arbeit. Es klingt nach vielen Akten, Konsortium klingt nämlich auch nach diesem Lederkoffer. Strenge Hierarchie. Diesen Koffer mit diesem ... Was man so aufmacht. Das ist eine Ansage. Mit diesem Code. Mein Rucksack hat kein Code, mein Rucksack braucht auch kein Code. Ich hätte gerne einen Job, wo der Inhalt meiner Tasche einen Code nötig macht. Ich hätte gerne eine Bauchtasche mit Code. So eine türkise, abgegriffene Bauchbeutel, aber mit einem Code dran. Und da sind meine Akten drin. Noch lieber hätte ich etwas, was das nötig macht. Inhalt, was das nötig macht, einen Code nötig macht. Ja, so wie ein Gerichtsprozess. Ich stehe gerade vor Gericht. So, einfach mal sich verklagen lassen, damit man Akten durch die Gegend tragen kann. Aber man darf eigentlich, wenn man so einen Aktenkoffer aufmacht, macht man immer links und rechts gleichzeitig auf. Klapp! Du willst nur ein lautes Geräusch erzeugen. Du willst nicht zweimal die Störung. Ich glaube, wenn jemand das erst rechts, dann links macht, drehen sich alle um und sagen, bitte, das ist ein Affront. Entschuldigung. Also ich glaube, so könnte sich ein Alien verraten. Das ist ein Affront im Konsortium. Konsortium ist ein Affront. Ich glaube, ein Alien haut den Aktenkoffer auf den Tisch und macht Klapp, Klapp und alle raus. Raus, Alien. Raus, Morgon. Alien, was man sagt zu Aliens, raus. Das ist die typische Reaktion. Hau ab, du! Keine Angst, nichts. Was wäre Independence, wenn wir einfach sagen würden, back it, hau. Lass mich in Ruhe. Ich meine, wahrscheinlich sind Aliens auch nicht furchteinflössend, weder militärisch noch von der Erscheinung. Ich glaube militärisch schon. Wenn die hier wären, hätten die Hindernisse auf sich genommen, wären die uns technisch deutlich überlegen. Doch, Florentin. Nein, ich glaube, man kann die, die kann sagen, dürfen wir hier sein? Und wir so, nö, ja, dann fahren wir wieder. Ja, okay.
Was, wenn die
super Angst einflüssten, wenn die so ein peinliches
Antriebsgeräusch haben?
Ja, super süss, aber dann so furchterregende Alien, wie aus dem Film Alien Monster mit so grossen Zähnen, furchtbaren Waffen, die dich sofort zum Skelett verwandeln, aber deren Antrieb ist ein ... Ich meine, so wird es doch auch sein, wenn die Menschheit endlich, endlich umsteigt auf Laserwaffen und der erste Heckler und Koch, Vorstandsvorsitzende, präsentiert den Aktenkoffer und sagt, meine Damen und Herren, wir haben sie endlich entwickelt, die erste Laserpistole, hier ist sie.
Und er nimmt so wenig ... Weil es eine sehr sichere Tasche ist.
Drei Klemmen. Ich krieg's immer noch nicht auf.
Ah, jetzt geht's. Okay, Entschuldigung.
Er nimmt diese Laserpistole raus,
tiefschwarz, mit Zacken und
Rillen und cool und so,
innen so ein roter pulsierender Energiekern.
Und dann kann ich
einmal demonstrativ einen Schuss abgeben, um die Aktionäre zu überzeugen von seiner Mächtigkeit. Und der Entwickler schon so. Und dann steht irgendwie so ein Praktikant muss sich hinstellen, irgendwie mit so einer Zielscheibe auf dem T-Shirt. Ja genau. Und dann. Der vor sich hält. Also das ist das Geräusch. Ja. Das ... ja, wir müssen leider ... Ja, fuck. Der Ingenieur sofort, ja, sorry, wir mussten leider, damit es so mächtig ist, mussten wir leider das Geräusch. Es geht nicht anders. Es ist leider der Fusionsreaktor, mit der Fusion ist es leider einfach genau dieses Geräusch. Ich glaube, Flontien, dass wir genau diesen Gag vor acht Folgen oder so schon mal gemacht haben. Wirklich? Nein. Aber jetzt, ich habe es auch vergessen, bis wir an diesem Moment waren, ich glaube, wir haben schon mal über Waffen gesprochen, die ein besonderes Geräusch machen müssen. Stimmt, ich glaube, du hast recht. Aber ohne Scheiß, ich habe es auch vergessen, ich habe es auch vergessen, jetzt sind wir im Midway, wir sind viel zu nah weit schon im Bit. Aber ist das jetzt die Dauer unseres Gedächtnisses in acht Folgen? Wir sind viel zu tief im Bit. Wir können nicht mehr raus. Wir müssen jetzt metamässig den Gag besprechen. Ich glaube, genau das ist unser Humor. Also nichts ist mehr unser Humor, wie etwas, was wir schon zum achten Mal jetzt besprechen. Aber Leute, das ist einfach, deswegen hören wir doch alle das Podcast. Ich glaube, die Leute, die immer schreiben, das habt ihr doch schon mal vor zehn Folgen erzählt, die freuen sich darüber, dass sie das entdeckt haben. Dass sie sagen, hey, ich bin da so tief drin. Die rufen doch auch nicht auf dem Rolling Stones Konzert. Ich will nicht schon wieder. I can get. Kenn ich schon. Habt ihr in Folge 18 schon mal gespielt?
Ja, aber ich glaube, du hast recht, mit so einem Raketenwerfer, ne?
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Aber war es nicht auch das Elektroauto?
Das haben wir auch schon neunmal betroffen.
Also wir sind auf eine Art jetzt auch durch.
Wir haben, wenn unser Humorhorizont so ein Kuchen ist, wir haben schon sieben von acht
Stücke gegessen.
Wir sind schon papsatt.
Wir sind papsatt und wir gucken uns wirklich so an, wer ist jetzt das letzte Stück noch, danach sind wir einfach durch.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir jemanden, einen Hörer hier hinsetzen, der die Folgen gut kennt, den besten. Eigentlich ist das Hörer, das Comedy-Konsortium müsste sich eigentlich zu Wort melden.
Eigentlich müssten wir.
Und bei Doppelungen eigentlich müsste so eine Lampe angehen.
Es müsste sich das Podcast-UFO-Konsortium zu Wort melden.
Wir müssten eigentlich den besten Hörer finden, mit dem besten Gedächtnis und dem grössten Fan, den hier hinsetzen. Und immer, wenn wir was sagen, was wir schon mal besprochen haben, muss er mit dem Kopf schütteln. Podcast sucht den Superhörer. Seid ihr der Superhörer, bewerbt euch. Bewerbt euch mal. Nicht bei uns? Bewerbt euch generell mal. Und wenn ihr es schafft, Glückwunsch. Wenn nicht, passt. Macht es euch einfach nochmal. Ist okay. Ist kein Problem. Man muss auch generell mal wieder so eine Gelassenheit einführen in der Welt. Es ist auch nicht schlimm, wenn ihr es nicht macht. Nee, wenn ihr es nicht macht. Oder wenn ihr stattdessen was anderes macht, was euch so ein bisschen schlechter macht. Ja, scheiß, scheiß mal drauf. Ja. Ihr müsst niemandem was beweisen. Ah. Wir leben alle nur einmal auf dieser Welt. Weiter. Ich habe nichts mehr. Ich habe nichts mehr. Ihr müsst nicht unbedingt immer allem was beweisen, ihr müsst euch nicht gerecht werden. Ihr seid euch nicht schuldig, ihr seid niemandem etwas schuldig. Glaubt ihr, wenn ihr auf eurem, zehn Minuten bevor ihr sterbt, wenn ihr irgendwo in so einer Gletscherspalte eingeklemmt seid, dann denkt ihr an die Momente zurück, wo ihr irgendwie eine Bewerbung geschrieben habt? Ja, und nicht abgeschickt habt. Nein, ihr denkt daran, wie kommt dieser scheiß Spalte raus und welche Entscheidung meines Lebens haben hierzu geführt? Und welches Körperteil könnte ich zur Not noch essen oder wo ist meine Körperwärme hin? Ihr bereut vielleicht, fuck, ich hätte meinen Arm nicht schon auf dem Weg hoch zum Berg essen sollen. Das bereut ihr vielleicht, okay? Aber wenn diese scheiss Bewerbung oder eurem Chef ordentlich die Meinung gegeigt hat, das ist euch da einen Glitterspalt, glaube ich, scheiss egal. Ja, oder ob ihr irgendwie die süße Carina aus der Nebenklasse angesprochen habt. Fuck Carina. Ist euch scheiss egal, ihr kämpft um euer fucking Leben, euch scheiss kalt. Okay? Wisst ihr, wie kalt es ist? Arschkalt. Ja, richtig saukalt. Fucking Carina. Also. Ich glaube, ich schreibe jetzt. Habt noch einen schönen Abend, haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche und ganz, ganz viel Spaß mit dem Eisbär-Emoji. Ja, schreibt den Welt um sich. Ja, benutzt ihn oft, damit er nicht ausschreibt. Benutzt ihn inflationär, damit der zumindest der Emoji nicht ausschreibt. Das wäre das Mindeste, was wir tun können als Menschheit, den Emoji
retten. Haut rein, macht's gut, bis nächste
Woche, wir hören uns. Macht's gut, bis dann, ciao!
Du lässt mich bei der Verabschiedung nie zu Wort kommen.
It's a Boy's Bird Production.